would you say your perspective that is  changing as you get a little older as  you're getting a little more cynical  about this stuff I don't know  listen I'm I guess I'm feeling like I'm  41 and my name is Kyle  which means I'm on borrowed time there's  no such thing as the old Kyle that's  true I produced yeah did I everyone  there's never been one in yeah I'm not  my name's not in history books there's  no the third that's supposed to die in a  free climbing accident in my early 20s  that's how Kyle's died Kyle is a pile of  bones and a Patagonia wind of death  where redbull sends flowers to my  funeral Oh wicked air bro we're doing  this all right so that's silly you get  you would you you gotta live now you  gotta live now you gotta you gotta just  live to the most I'm havin a good time  yeah I don't know  you